nene leakes was all smiles at the
associates for breast and prostate
cancer studies annual Mother's Day lunch
in Beverly Hills where she was honored
with the organization's Woman of
Achievement Award everything I do is for
my children in my husband the Woman of
Achievement Award
yes what does this mean to you
everything I couldn't even believe they
said nene leakes
okay that's gonna be number one when
they said okay nene leakes i was like
yes it means a lot to me it really
really does you know as you know my
husband was diagnosed with stage 3 colon
cancer and so every since then we have
been all over this whole cancer thing
because it was devastating to our family
but I'm happy to say today that Gregg is
much better we don't know if he's free
of cancer he is much better I was going
to be my next question how is Gregg
doing say and how are you and Gregg
doing today Gregg and I are doing good
Gregg is doing great he took a body scan
I think two days ago PET scan to see if
there's any cancer in his body if it had
spread to anywhere he'll get the results
next week all right
so fingers crossed I know he's good
he looks good he lost weight in the way
he lost it looks amazing on him so I
know he's good this is a Mother's Day
luncheon you're a mommy anti-glare mommy
yeah what is the best piece of advice
you've ever gotten about being a mom oh
my god oh I can tell you this is the
best piece of advice I've gotten but I
had to learn this that your children
need a hug no matter the age so even you
got grown kids I need a hug because a
lot of parents think that when they're
little you taking them to first grade
and kindergarten or elementary school
you hugging kids give mommy a kiss and
then when they get a middle school of
course they don't want to kiss but you
still need to hug your child so I
learned that hugs your kids bringing
back to the event today you were able to
give a great platform to this kind of
talk on housewife on what was it like to
get the response from the fans and the
viewers for maybe going through the same
thing you and Greg and your families
well I can say that I had a lot of fans
to reach out to me
caretakers we're emailing me left and
right saying we understand what you are
going through now there were people who
did not understand what a caretaker role
is or they just didn't understand me
saying I was frustrated like why are you
frustrated your has a while I got that
but you know I was frustrated because I
was a caretaker and being a caretakers
heart is one of those roles where you
just don't get any shine for that you
know you just be a caretaking shut up
[Music]